The earth sits comfortably in its orbit,
tilted on its access at 23 degrees,
knock the planet over, and it
wouldn't be the earth as you know it.
How can a slight change in its actual
tilt make the planet uninhabitable?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the
earth's axis was tilted by 90 degrees.
Only two planets in the solar
system lie on their sides,
Uranus and the Dorf Planet Pluto.
Now,
if something took the earth off its stand,
the blue planet would have no chance
of developing any complex life on its
surface.
But let's start at the beginning.
This actual till or obliquity is what
drives the seasons here on earth.
Before the collision
that created the moon,
the Earth's axis was
slowly wobbling around,
somewhere between zero and 85 degrees.
Then our newly for moon stabilized it.
But if that collision
happened at a different time,
things would have turned out
very different here on earth.
It would be a strange new world.
As the earth made its way through orbit,
it's poles would be pointing
straight towards the Sun.
One hemisphere would be shrouded in
darkness for six months straight,
while the other would be getting
cooked by the blazing sunlight.
One day on earth would last a whole year
at the North Pole.
The daytime temperatures would rise
to a broiling 50 degrees a day.
At the South Pole would be even worse
because the South Pole would be located
away from climate
controlling ocean currents.
It would heat up to an
almost boiling 80 degrees.
The polls would soak up so much heat from
the sun that they wouldn't even freeze
during the six month long night.
You wouldn't recognize the steaming
equatorial tropics with a 90 degree axial
tilt. Part of the equator would
stay in Cayston ice all year round.
At some point in this earth's existence,
our continents would get clumped
together around one of the Poles.
Inland temperatures in the
daytime would get truly hellish.
Reaching the boiling temperature of
water clouds could help the situation and
not let all the water vapor off
the planet, but you wouldn't know.
You wouldn't stick around that
long in this scorching heat.
The best case scenario with see just
a few kinds of bacteria survive.
Those bacteria might evolve
into more complex lifeforms,
but they wouldn't be anywhere close
to how complex we turned out to be.
The reason would be a lack of oxygen.
Green plants would be having a hard
time surviving during the six months of
complete darkness. They dropped their
seeds at nightfall to grow after sunrise,
but in these conditions, would they
even have evolved in the first place?
Interestingly enough,
if the earth was 60 million
kilometers further away from the sun,
a 90 degree axial tilt wouldn't be so bad.
The temperatures at the polls would never
raise above 46 degrees during the day.
The coldest it would get at
night would be three degrees.
The only place covered with ice
would be the highest mountains.
So you see simply orbiting a star in
the habitable zone doesn't mean that a
planet is actually capable
of sustaining life.
We're the lucky ones living here on earth.
Maybe one day we'll discover another
exoplanet just like our home,
but that's a story for another.
What if.